jetzt sprechen wir mit opas ag herr
thomas holz erstens jetzt gleich
zugeschaltet er hat in afghanistan
gedient und hat dadurch direkten kontakt
zu ortskräfte gehabt und sie haben guten
tag sind sie einen leserbrief auch
geschrieben an die fans und darin sich
geäußert zu den orts kräften sie sind
vielen begegnet
also ich muss hier einschränkend
hinzufügen ich bin nicht sehr viel in
ortskräfte begegnet mir waren als
kommandant des camps warehouse einige
ortskräfte
zugeordnet die uns bei der camp
organisation sauberkeit und so weiter
geholfen haben und dazu habe ich mich
geäußert sehr prononciert geäußert aber
ich glaube dass meine einschätzung nicht
ganz falsch war ich bin gerne bereit
einzuräumen dass auch ich am anfang
dieses einsatzes und auch unmittelbar
nach dem ende zunächst etwas blauäugig
war bei einer diskussionsveranstaltung
mit dem wdr
2006 also nach meiner rückkehr mein
berufsverband hatte mich gebeten daran
teilzunehmen habe ich mich sehr sehr
sehr engagiert für diesen einsatz
ausgedrückt und zwar aus folgendem grund
meine einschätzung war uns deutschen ist
nach 1945 auch geholfen worden
und jetzt haben wir ich sag mal frei
nach kant unsere verdammte pflicht und
schuldigkeit auch in einem anderen staat
in einer anderen gesellschaft unseren
beitrag zur verbesserung der
lebensbedingungen zu leisten das war
damals meine ehrliche auffassung das ist
auch überall nachvollziehbar ich habe im
laufe der zeit jedoch feststellen müssen
und dass wir vielleicht denn doch zu
blauäugig und mit zu weit gesteckten
zielen aber ich möchte sage ich ja auch
hier nichts neues in diesen einsatz
gegangen sind ihm geführt haben und dann
halt eben erkennen mussten dass wir nur
eine hauchdünne oberschicht wenn
überhaupt erreicht haben und es ist uns
leider nicht gelungen ist
die breiten gesellschaftlichen schichten
einzudringen
jetzt haben wir in den vergangenen tagen
immer wieder hier bei bild live auch
darüber berichtet dass wir wissen wollen
wer da wirklich in den flugzeugen sei es
wäre wirklich aus geflogen war und es
ist jetzt raus gekommen dass nur die
geringste zahl der war die sich da in
den rettungsfliegern der bundeswehr
gefunden haben tatsächlich ortskräfte
waren und jetzt sagen sie noch obendrauf
natürlich bin ich auch bei den orts
kräften müssen wir ganz genau hingucken
denn das sind nicht menschen die uns
geholfen haben weil sie unsere werte
teilen
langsam also so weit wie sie mir das
jetzt unterstellen gehe ich natürlich
gehe ich nicht ich will nicht das habe
ich auch in diesem brief geschrieben
ich will nicht ausschließen dass wir
durchaus den ein oder anderen erreicht
haben aber sie müssen sich einmal an die
afghanische gesellschaft betrachten für
philanthropische überlegung ist dort
kein platz jeden tag und das hatte ihr
korrespondent jetzt dem ich von dem ich
dem ich her herzlich grüße und dem hier
viel glück wünschen bitte passen sie auf
sich auf
hat jetzt festgestellt es ist jeden tag
ein kampf ums überleben und daher können
wir unsere maßstäbe nicht auf diese
gesellschaft übertragen das wäre hybris
was wir dann tun würden von daher wenn
sie sich dieses berühmte bild aus der c
17 der amerikaner angucken mit der 830
menschen ausgeflogen worden sind da
waren vielleicht zwei oder drei prozent
frauen vielleicht noch zwei oder drei
prozent kinder der rest waren männer die
sich ganz einfach weil sie die stärkeren
waren dingwelt durchgekämpft haben und
da das ist ja ich war eine ich trete
hier niemanden solar das ist keine
beleidigung oder sonst irgendwas das ist
eine pure tatsachenfeststellung
was glauben sie was hat das für
konsequenzen für uns hier in deutschland
wie sehen sie auch überhaupt die aktion
ortskräfte zurück zu holen zu wollen man
weiß bisher überhaupt nicht so richtig
von was für einer zahl man ausgehen soll
die bundeskanzlerin sagte gestern es
sind so zwischen zehn und 40 tausend
filme wenn uns das jetzt einmal genau
anschauen sie die sie waren in
afghanistan sie kennen einige ortskräfte
was wir jetzt die richtige strategie
also die habe ich natürlich nicht hätte
ich die selbst in der bundesregierung
aber ich habe sie nicht und ich bilde
mir auch nicht ein eine zu haben mein
leserbrief zielte darauf ab auf eine
gewisse blauäugigkeit eine euphorie und
was weiß ich was alles zu antworten dass
wir denjenigen helfen müssen ich
unterstreiche denjenigen die wirklich
mit uns auf dem gefechtsfeld waren die
für uns wirklich den kopf hingehalten
haben dass wir denen helfen müssen ist
über da gibt es überhaupt keine
diskussion
und natürlich auch ihren familien aber
das sind wenn sie mal sehen wie viele
jetzt plötzlich ortskräfte gewesen sein
wollen wenn sie sehen wie viele die
niederländer ausgeflogen haben oder die
franzosen dann würde dann möchte ich
doch zu einer gewissen vorsicht machen
das war mein credo
da haben wir sehr aufmerksam gelesen in
ihrem leserbrief in der faz sehr
bemerkenswert der text wenn sie jetzt
sehen was die deutsche politik äußert
der für die verteidigungsministerin der
außenminister auch die kanzlerin selbst
der fallen zahlen 70.000 menschen
vielleicht über 100.000 menschen wir
bereiten uns also wieder auf eine große
flüchtlingswelle vor und im zentrum
stehen immer die ortskräfte wie wirkt es
auf sie
also das ist für mich wird hier versucht
über diesen über diese diesen trafo
ortskräfte
offenbar jedwede form von
kontrolle
möglichst zu vermeiden denn es könnte ja
in einer aufgeheizten stimmung
von interessierten kreisen
durchaus aufgenommen werden wenn wir
haben ja auch schon ja bitte
entschuldigung ich hab sie unterbrochen
es kann ja es sind ja auch und das hat
sich auch herausgestellt mit das war ja
auch gar nicht zu vermeiden wenn sie am
flughafen in kabul
das war übrigens ein fehler back
aufzugeben von dort wäre die evakuierung
früher und viel besser zu organisieren
gewesen aber da bin ich auch nicht der
einzige der dies äußert
dann können sie nicht vermeiden dass
menschen die wir besser dort gelassen
hätten
sich aufgrund ihrer stärke ihrer kleinen
physischen stärke dort in die flugzeuge
hineingedrängt haben und das war ja auch
offensichtlich
jetzt haben sie selber erfahrungen mit
orts kräften gemacht und kenne natürlich
sicher auch viele erzählungen von
anderen führenden bundeswehr kräften in
afghanistan
wenn ich formulieren würde achtung liebe
bundesregierung auch ortskräfte können
böse menschen sein was würden sie mir
antworten ja ich möchte das lehrt das
lehrt die tägliche praxis wir haben doch
ortskräfte erlebt sowohl bei uns dort
bei uns deutschen weniger aber zum
beispiel bei anderen staaten die sich in
der not die als selbstmordattentäter
sich plötzlich entpuppt haben wir haben
ortskräfte erlebt die von den als
wachmänner dach männer eingesetzt von
den wachtürmen aus wenn konvois die koki
camps verlassen haben dies nach draußen
gemeldet haben man muss doch mal das
habe ich ja nun auch in meinem
leserbrief zum ausdruck gebracht wir
müssen uns doch mal die gesellschaft
dort anschauen in afghanistan ist der
einzelne nicht überlebensfähig und
insbesondere keine frau das heißt wir
sind hier mit einer gesellschaft
konfrontiert in der der zusammenhalt der
familien der clans der stämme
überlebenswichtig ist wie gehen mit
völlig anderen mittel mit ganz anderen
kulturen hier an etwas heran als wir uns
möglicherweise vom bequemen deutschen
sessel aus vorstellen können ich kann
das den menschen dass diese menschen
dort versuchen in dieser umgebung zu
überleben das kann man ja niemand
vorwerfen wir müssen damit das werfe ich
auch niemand vor wir müssen uns nur
dieser dieser tatsache klar werden dass
ist das ist das was ich auch propagiert
habe und was ich mit diesem leserbrief
zum ausdruck bringen wollte danke für
das anstoßen dieser wichtigen debatte an
den oberster die thomas holz der selbst
in afghanistan gedient hatte und da auch
kontakt zur orts kräften hatte danke
dafür er sei holz bitte stellen und wie
schon gesagt ihrem kollegen in kabul
alles gute das geben wir mit auf den weg
auf jeden fall und es hier mit
angekommen danke herr sauber
[Musik]